[Music]
oh look it's miss marvel in the opening
credits after her show's already run and
still know she-hulk even though this is
her show it's almost like marvel's
making his characters earn their way
into the opening title and we won't
stand for that kind of bullying elitist
crap around here marvel what is the
responsibility of those with power is it
great power then i think we've
established that the responsibility is
also to be great like for instance
marvel has great power so they're
responsible to milk every last cent out
of every single character ever created
for their shareholders am i content
incorrectly i don't have a savage and
walters look there it is calling this
look savage i might go with befuddled
constipated disgusted or elvis-ish but
definitely not savage the only hulking
out i'm gonna do is in the legal sense
damn it show what does any of this mean
what is the legal sense of hulking out
oh right last time i was watching perry
mason there was that one scene where the
judge was like are you invoking the
standard legal precedent of hulking out
vis-a-vis your client's mediation and
culpability and then perry was like no
your honor i'm not i'm simply addressing
my client's relationship to hulking as
it relates to arbitration and sentencing
classic mason it's true i am a hulk and
apparently a deadpool any other supers
you want to crib from she pool dead hulk
and i'm guessing you're not going to be
able to focus on this fun lawyer show
until you know all about that i mean i
know these shows get studio notes but i
didn't expect them to just write them
directly into the script a few months
ago i went on a road trip with my cousin
bruce fourth wall breakeration cheetos
and chopsticks yes i'm assuming there
was a brand deal headed into this
episode and the writers had to find a
clever way to introduce cheetos into
their storyline that's fine make your
money but in the car wait until the
scene between hulk and she-hulk on the
beach when it makes sense eating
chopstick cheetos in a car is worse than
texting and driving you're not the only
genius in the family no there's there's
also chet shed
chad who the [ __ ] is chad and is he
really a genius will he show up in this
show is he getting his own ched hulk
show how dare you drop this ched bomb
and not follow up on it this episode
obviously captain america wasn't working
do you ever get the impression that the
marvel show spent about 40 of their time
looking through fan theories and then
spinning plot points out of them
oh come on they're never that easy to
press
sorry i may be experiencing a bit of
residual trauma from helping my nephew
out of the car seat recently those
[ __ ] buckles are brutal on my
manicure well that happened fast did
they have a conversation before the
accident that explained a blood mixture
would be transformative the time to
explain that is before the accident oh
look another qr code that piques your
interest and lets you down with a link
to a comic so this in as always is cue
reading writing this helpful instruction
on the chalkboard outside the stalls
instead of inside them where it's more
needed but you do need shoes because
this is a public bag
wait do women carry around an extra pair
of shoes with them and they just happen
to be close to the right size even if
both of those things are true i'm still
seeing how complicated it must be to
leave the house as a woman i don't need
you to put makeup on me um yes you do
people who push their perception of need
onto the person who has a need but
insist they need not
you can barely see it but he-hulk dives
in at the last moment here to ex-machina
these punk [ __ ] and honestly the sin
is that the show didn't let jen tear one
of their arms off and beat the other two
with it so jen wakes up in banish bunker
without a clue as to where she is how
she got there or if she's safe you'd
think her cousin would leave a note for
her to find or some food or really just
any indication that she's well but no
the show has to build tension for us and
throws out the likelihood that banner
would have been a caring host offering
more than some suspicious water and a
creepy change of clothes installing a
speaker that just serves this corner of
a concrete stairway you never have a
choice with these names i mean you never
have a choice with the names other
people call you but you always have a
choice in how you refer to yourself
bruce i didn't spend my whole junior
high introducing myself to people as job
of the butt just because of that one
incident in gym class that is not the
sentence to take a pause on groups did
he take a pause let's listen after the
wreck and you got a lethal dose of gamma
radiation lethal nope you jumped in
without even giving him a chance to
pause not that i blame you because the
real sin is that bruce even uses the
word lethal to begin with when he knows
that it's not going to kill you the way
it's synthesized gamma i was able to use
it to completely heal my arm neat great
can we get back to the person who
suddenly turned into a hulk and is
trying to process what this means to her
life
this is not going away and now jen will
make several decent suggestions as to
how it could go away which will all be
thwarted away by some classic marvel
yada yada bullsh look it can't go away
because then there isn't a show that's
the real reason and if you're gonna make
she-hulk into some sort of deadpool
light then i'm disappointed she didn't
turn to the camera and just say so how
in the hell has she been eating those
silver dollar pancakes is she literally
taking a single bite out of each one why
are there six half-eaten silver dollar
pancakes on this plate who only eats
half of a silver dollar pancake also
this [ __ ] plate is ridiculous or
maybe it's a bowl whatever it is it's
not meant to help anyone especially a
hulk eat food we're gonna rock back and
forth like a boat and why eat on an
uneven tree stump is this table designed
to infuriate people and turn them into
hulks because i think that is happening
to me right now put on a pixar movie
when bing bong jumps out of the wagon
using corporate synergy to reopen my
only recently healed bing bong wounds i
just feel like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die do you have a plan b for that
ah no banner is oddly happy about the
way he delivers this line sure he's
confident the instincts will kick in but
what if they don't
use this chamber for you
hulk is going to continue to be
excellent at she-hulk sins isn't she
[Applause]
this doesn't work on dogs do you really
think it would work on a she-hulk this
is incredible you don't have an alter
ego you're the only only one in there as
far as i can tell i just waited until
now to start speaking normally instead
of growling and ripping doors off so
that it can be a big revelation for the
audience did it work that's about a
million dollars worth of damage back
there by the way okay blame shifter you
put her into the situation in the first
place what did you think was going to
happen a tiny turtle hulk with a glowing
unicorn horn was going to pop out of her
ass and spray harmless rainbow glitter
around the room fine
teach me how to
hulk
please sure i've got this so basically
you're a monster so powerful that it's
impossible to hurt or contain you until
the plot needs you to be hurt or
contained how am i doing so far first
we're gonna practice some mindfulness
with a few yoga techniques hold on how's
she back to herself now we just came
from an it's not easy being not green
conversation pondering how she didn't
know how to turn back and we're just
starting the next scene with her as jen
what happened between then and now for
her to turn back hold in your farts
which reminds me of that time i decided
to attend a yoga class after eating a
bean burrito yes it was brutal yes it
was embarrassing yes you can hold in
your farts but it comes with severe
consequences and a high likelihood that
your intestines will rebel for the rest
of the day oh i thought it was about
getting my butt tight as hell
[Laughter]
tatiana maslany is just the best
[Music]
you'd think the banner would have
reinforced all of the furniture in his
hulk bungalow already you do revert back
to gen 4 when you sleep he says while
currently sitting beside her bed having
just invaded her sleepy privacy like a
[ __ ] creep considering jen doesn't
have her own clothes and all she wears
was originally banners it's an absolute
sin that we never saw bruce in this
shirt of his is the air horn really
necessary for comedy absolutely
misunderstanding how comedy works you're
gonna need two wardrobes
one for jen and one for your whole body
which immediately brings into question
the entirety of this show which has both
jyn and hulk gin in the same clothes the
entire time this hulk training montage
goes on for all of the none of this
matters because these powers are
undefinable amounts of time but when did
she get to shop for perfectly fitted
she-hulk jean shorts all i've been doing
is showing you the downsides of being a
hulk downsides did i miss that bummer
vibe during the last montage of fun hulk
moves to upbeat music all buzz
rejected slogan for the toy story space
ranger spin ride at disney somehow makes
it into the episode built this bar
by hand yeah me and tony hmm a nostalgic
place with historical importance to a
character currently training another
super powered person i wonder what will
happen to it in this episode bruce
i'm not gonna be a superhero what else
you gonna do as a hulk defining
someone's career prospects by their
physical appearance i'm tall okay why
does that mean i have to put the
circular orange bouncy thing into the
circular orange metal thing here's the
thing bruce i'm great at controlling my
anger i do it all the time
when i'm catcalled in the street
when incompetent men explain my own area
of expertise to me the way this show
uses jen being a woman to inform her
abilities and control is kind of genius
level storytelling stuff nicely done
marvel i'm giving you this one more sin
back but don't take it for granted okay
i'm asking you to reconsider and by
asking he means forcibly detaining you
what you think you can just say a bunch
of me things like that and then take off
she said she loved you and wanted to
leave you said no she said she didn't
want to be a superhero like you you said
she has to be and you're saying that's
mean instead of smart hulk can we go
with fragile ego hulk the two hulks will
now fight each other because how'd we
know it was marvel if they didn't stage
some pointless battle between two heroes
that doesn't really tell us anything
about their relative powers but instead
just gives us some sketchy cgi to look
at applauding someone to death may be
the most passive aggressive superhero
power in the history of the universe oh
and the dumbest i respect that he
doesn't mean that i might be able to get
on board with some fourth wall breakage
but did hulk just hear her talk to the
audience as well are we flea bagging
this [ __ ] or just malcolm in the
middling because there's a big
difference there and i need to know the
rules
and she knows she's in a show i do not
understand how to process where this
lands in the multiverse and my part in
it is this like the neverending story
and i'm riding along with childlike
empress or some [ __ ] don't screw this up
walters assholing so hard that you're
willing to put your own financial
well-being at stake by psyching out your
own partner ladies and gentlemen of the
jury
convenient titania's titanic terrorism
triggering tatiana's totally timely
titular transformation is convenient i'm
ready to give my closing argument now
but first shouldn't everyone be tended
to a ceiling beam collapses people were
nearly smashed by a desk there's debris
everywhere and the jury likely needs to
take a minute to reconnect with reality
we're all impressed that jen has the
emotional fortitude to bypass the shock
of the attack and get back to the task
at hand but not everyone is gonna keep
pace maybe ask if everyone's okay first
captain america
a little help for all the parents who
had to fill in the blank on this one
here are some options captain america
funded several charities captain america
far got to buy milk captain america
filled his greatest wishes before dying
heroically which was
green
green
green
isms in my opinion are not good
a person should not believe in an ism
you should believe in himself
seems like he was pretty pretty busy
pretty
pretty
pretty good you're hulk again
smart old wow
yeah i didn't come up with it you you
never have a choice with these names
bruce
shut down all the garbage matches on the
detective level will ya i'm sorry the
idea of being a superhero is not
appealing to me i'm not you i don't want
your life why wouldn't you listen to
someone who's been through all this
before shut up you're not my dad
maybe i'm wrong on this one but for me
the beast doesn't include selling out
gonna be a consent of the movie we're
still in the middle of making it that's
true sir but there's been a new
breakthrough in home video marketing
there is yes instant cassettes they're
out in stores before the movie is
finished
oh yeah